hi guys in this video I want to talk
about statin drugs they really had
trivial benefits with a great cost okay
now the studies basically indicate that
two out of a hundred people will end up
with a heart attack not dying from a
heart attack they'll end up with a heart
attack but if you take statins it drops
it down to one out of a hundred people
okay so if we take two to one that's a
50% reduction in heart attacks right
that's significant if someone to tell
you oh yeah you have i can drop your
chance of getting heart attack by 50%
you probably would do it but these
aren't whole numbers these are fractions
if you take to it 100 to 100 that's
actually only a 1% decrease not a 50% so
they use words like relative risk
factors and they have no legal
definition so if I were to tell you you
have oh you're going to have a 1%
decrease of having heart attack if you
take the statin you knee might not do it
here's some of the risks to get this one
percent increased risk of Parkinson's it
depletes your coenzyme q-10 that's going
to actually make your heart work harder
and create more problems with the heart
especially if you're getting older
there's over 300 adverse reactions with
statins muscle damage nerve damage liver
damage endocrine system damage cancer
and heart damage so this is a huge risk
statins blocked enzyme that makes
cholesterol now the problem is that your
body makes cholesterol for a reason it
makes 3,000 milligrams of cholesterol
every single day that's a lot of
cholesterol that's like the equivalent
of the cholesterol in 300 strips of
bacon or the amount of cholesterol in a
pound of butter or 14 eggs for a lot of
cholesterol so why would you body make
so much well because it's the precursor
for hormones like testosterone that you
need as you as it decreases testosterone
decreases with age you need more
cholesterol to make more testosterone as
well as cortisol versus stress hormones
so we need that we age but if you take
this you'll cut down the raw material
for making this for most cellular
membranes LDL that's the low-density
lipoproteins okay that's the so-called
bad cholesterol here's what it is it's a
protein that carries cholesterol into
the arteries as a healer as a band-aid
to patch things up that's why you get a
clogged artery because there's a lesion
there already that the cholesterol comes
in and starts to patch it up so LDL is
not actually bad it's late on the chain
of events your brain needs cholesterol
to function your eyes especially the
retina needs cholesterol biocells to
help you digest okay so you need
cholesterol and the most ironic thing is
that high cholesterol doesn't cause
heart attacks in that first place I'll
put some links down below cholesterol is
a necessary thing it's late in the chain
of events but because it's in the
arteries people freaked out so how can
you have so many people tens of
thousands of people taking this
medication and buying into this whole
cholesterol scare it's one word fear all
of doctor has to say is what you want a
heart attack you better take your
medication okay so if this makes sense
and you logically want to do it but
you're scared here's what I recommend
you do cut down the sugar in your diet
cut down the refined carbs I put a link
down below if the ketogenic diet to
intimate a fasting that will greatly
help lower your cholesterol and once
it's normal get with your doctor to come
off this medication if the doctor still
wants you to take the medication when
your values are normal find another
doctor thanks for watching you know just
wanted to take a moment out to thank you
for your amazing feedback that you guys
are giving me it's just mind-blowing the
successes the wins I created a link down
below so you can actually type out your
full success story and if you have a
before and after with weight loss that
would be awesome
if you don't have a success with weight
but other things just put an image of
yourself and your personal success story
and I would love to read it and also
share it with others so I want to just
thank you in advance for doing that but
there's a link down below fill it out
but I can't wait to read it